I'm ready to make love a priority Jordan
Rogers quickly became a bachelorette
front-runner on Monday night's premiere
kissing Jojo Fletcher and getting the
coveted first impression rose I am
really excited about you I feel very
comfortable with the handsome guy is
also being talked about because he is
the younger brother of none other than
the NFL quarterback Aaron Rodgers but
things quickly took a turn after the
show a woman named Brittany Farrar
called Jordan out on Instagram
look at her caption she seems to be
claiming he's a cheater and saying he
has always wanted to be famous and
here's a twist Farrar who is a trainer
based in Nashville appears to be close
pals with Aaron's girlfriend actress
Olivia Munn the two appear in several
pictures together on social media now
Jordan has not responded to Farrar's
claim which actually isn't surprising
bachelor and bachelorette contestants
are careful on social media while the
show is airing so they don't
accidentally reveal what's to come but
Monday night Jordan did have this to say
about a past relationship of his I
wasn't loved but I was so focused on
football that I didn't make time for
anything else and Farrar wrote on
Instagram quote tune in next week for
more BS honestly I thought the
connection between Jordan and Jojo was
clear Monday night but do you like him
for Jojo let's talk about it on Twitter
I'm at one